thanks for coming so today I'll be
talking about how you can use as your ml
to operationalize functions models
anything you really want actually and
publish them and make them available its
web surface so we'll be using the a
dremel client library which is up on
github and published a pipe I the cheese
shop so that you can just pip install it
and get started with it I'll be doing
this with as your email notebooks which
is a new feature that we added to a
shower Mel just this week and I'll show
you how we can actually integrate this
with web applications as well so that
you can actually consume the model from
somewhere else so this is going to
basically all be a demo so here I am
over in Azure m else to do I have
experiments I have web services and I
have the new notebooks feature that we
just added and if I go and click on
notebooks you'll see I have a couple of
notebooks that I've actually already
created inside of my workspace so here
I'm going to open my oil forecasting
notebook which will just train a simple
model which is going to try to predict
the prices of oil in the future alright
so typical notebook first thing I do is
bring in a bunch of dependencies that i
need and set up Matt plot libs that's
nice and then I'm going to connect to my
ashram ml workspace so if i go back and
look over here i have a data sets tab
and i've uploaded an oil price csv
already that i can download directly
into my notebook and so this chunk of
code is going to go connect my workspace
yeah that data set out and bring it in
as a pandas dataframe and i can see
quickly kind of what that data looks
like i can also of course plot that data
inside of my notebook and we can see
where oil prices are going I can take a
sample of that 150 elements and then
plot that sample and so on and then
finally i'm just going to train a model
which i'm not going to get into the
details of training the model but we can
see that the model gets trained and it's
going to have some predictions about
where the prices of oil are going in the
future but once I've got that model
trained I want to take it and publish it
to the web and be able to consume it and
this can be done pretty easily so we
have our ashram ml library which I've
imported earlier and it has a new
services package that we just added and
inside of that services package there's
a number of decorators that configure
how your service is going to get
published and there's decorators for
consuming services as well so the
published service here will actually be
used or the published decorator here
will be used and say take this function
and publish it there's a decorator here
where I can specify the types of my
inputs and this is the syntax we're
using for Python 2 we only support
Python 2 on the back end right now we
should be supporting Python 3 in the
future and that point the syntax gets
nicer because you can just use function
annotations for this stuff and I have a
return type here and so this takes an
int which is the week that I want the
prediction for and it's going to return
back a floating point which is the
predicted price and what's interesting
about this function is it's just
accessing my model from within the
notebook and when we take it and publish
it we're actually going to publish the
model along with it so we look at the
function that you're publishing analyze
it see what Global's it's actually
closing over we will pickle those up
send the whole thing to the server and
we'll have your function running up on
the server exactly as it so as long as
you're accessing things that can be
serialized using pickle we can take
whatever you're building up inside of
the notebook and just kind of magically
send it up there and after defining this
forecast is just a usual function I can
call for
locally and I get my prediction back no
big surprise there but if I look what's
on forecast you can see there's actually
this new service property that we've
attached to it and if I invoke the
service property let's first look at the
service property I can see that it's
this object that has an endpoint
associated with it I can look at what's
on that and there's a few interesting
properties here there's an API key
there's a help Earl there's a service ID
which is a good that it's published with
so if I want to republish and update the
service I can do that and there's an
earl which is the end point if i look at
the help Earl I can take that and pull
that up in my browser and you can see I
get this nice description of what the
API looks like so I see information on
how to send request headers I see
information on a sample input where it
takes a week I see information on what
the response is going to come back like
and if I scroll down I even get some
sample code for how to consume this
function so if I want to consume it from
C sharp or are that codes just easily
available to me obviously it's just a
rest endpoint so I can consume it from
my language of choice I don't have to
use that sample code and I can now
actually go and execute this thing on
the server so the first time I execute
it it's going to take a little bit while
a little while it will need to be
deployed to an actual machine that's
running it and this can be distributed
across a lot of machines so that my
function can scale and I can have a lot
of different clients that are running on
it so sometimes I'll invoke it a couple
times in a row and it will be hitting
different machines and so the first two
or three invocations might be a little
bit slow so there came back I can
execute it with a different number yeah
different result
and kind of one of the really cool
things about this is we also have a map
function on here so if I want to send a
bunch of values up to that all at once
and just do one network call I can do
that and looks like I hit a different
server but if we wait a little bit will
see that this will come back and I'll
actually get the forecast for the first
50 weeks and hopefully this won't take
too long while that's running I can
actually also download this notebook and
i'm just going to save it locally and so
there that completed and there's the
results for the next 50 weeks so one
thing I don't want you to think is that
this is just strictly tied to our
notebook offering I can actually do all
this development locally and publish
things that are running locally I'll
show this real quickly just running
through a local notebook I'm going to
change it so that instead of reading the
data from a shore ml I'll read it from a
local data set oh that's an interesting
download let's try downloading that
again
so here I'm running on localhost now
instead of running up on Azure ml and
I'm going to drop this code and do
that instead
I think I actually should be data
so those imports are certainly taking
some time to run
there we go
oil price and now I can run through this
and you'll see you will get the exact
same results
here I'm running against a slightly
older version of Python so I get this
ssl warning as I publish the function
but once again we've published it and
it's up and running I can look at I can
invoke it locally still and I can look
at the Earl on it and if we look at this
Earl will see that we actually published
it to a slightly different location that
was 535 and this is 702 so same
experience developing locally or
remotely if you want to use the notebook
service it's kind of nice you can have
all of your data sets collected there in
one spot and everything will be
persisted in the cloud for you but what
I really want to do with this service is
take it and put it into an application
so here I've switched over to python
tools for visual studio and I have a
simple bottle app that I pre created and
I'm going to fill in a new route here
which is going to do the prediction and
when they come over here and get the
information about my service and drop
this function in so to consume an
existing a dremel service instead of
using the publish decorator I will use
the service decorator so I import my
services module and I switch this to
service and each service has associated
with a a in point which is this Earl so
I'll take that and paste that in doesn't
it be a Unicode string and it has a AP I
key and so these are there's different
workspaces up on a shore ml there's free
workspaces and there's paid work spaces
and this is the key that allows access
to this so when you're using a paid
workspace random people can't
up in and execute your function or if
you're using a free workspace random
people can't come in and use your
awesome API unless you want them to so
because this is a published service I
don't really need a function body here
so I'm just going to replace that with a
pass it's going to execute remotely the
service decorator is going to replace
this function with an actual callable
object which is going to go off and do
the dispatch to the cloud and then my
prediction API is using that and now I
just need to come in and create a form
over here and that's going to go to my
prediction route and we're going to have
an input that takes the week and we're
going to have a submit button and then I
need something that's going to display
this so I'll make a predict template
which my predict route is using and I
think I called that value may just
confirm the yup so I can run this look
Lane ow just to make sure it's going to
work and will launch the little local
built-in web server and launch my web
browser here as this just kind of chugs
along as slow as possible
I'm sorry it's a template file so bottle
is this micro web framework and it has
its own template een language and it
will take dictionaries and map various
things out and replace them and yes it's
very similar to a lot of the other
templating languages that exist for
little micro frameworks but bottle has
its own I think it calls its like a
simple simple template een engine it's
pretty straightforward stuff so I can
submit my query and if all goes well we
invoke the service and we get the price
prediction so finally you know I just I
don't want to just run this locally what
I really want to do is make my awesome
oil price prediction service available
so i can right click on my project here
and i've configured this all ready to
publish to asia and so i can quickly
just deploy it with basically one click
of a button and it will take my app all
of its dependencies that I've installed
into a local virtual environment here
and publish those up to a shiur web apps
formerly known as a juror websites and I
can now have my site running in the
cloud where anyone can go off and hit it
and try these oil price predictions so
if anyone wants to actually try it it
will be serviced demoed as your websites
net
as it loads for the first time
yes I I created that a couple days ago
it's a little bit surprising that that
simple the name is available but yeah so
there we go it's running the cloud
anyone can hit it and use this super
super fantastic model that's built on
super outdated data so that's cool we
can do all this stuff with in Python but
I think one of the values of azure ml is
its drag and drop you I that it's very
easy to use and very approachable for
people who aren't don't have a strong
programming skill and our background and
so I can come over here and well there's
my to web services that i published but
if i click on notebooks just what i
meant to do i can see that i have this
other notebook which is the NCAA
notebook so if you saw the keynote on
Saturday Chris demoed this a little bit
during Joseph speech and so here I can
pop into the documentation for this so
this is a endpoint that was created
entirely inside of azure ml and it takes
a few different inputs here and one of
the differences between something that i
published from python is it has this
name parameter which is match all of the
parameters in python right now or input
one and it has some named outputs and it
even has multiple outputs that are being
returned instead of just a single one
and you know it has various input types
and so on and kind of the same
consumption code that we saw before and
so I can consume this exact same
function from Python here i have the api
oral an API key I have that service
decorator that we saw before when I was
consuming my Python function we have the
type definitions so one thing to watch
out for is our
brings your Unicode and so when we
specify our input types here they get
specified as Unicode as well these input
name and output names are special
because someone created this service
using Azure ml and they were able to
name those and so we have to match those
so i can define my service here and i
can execute it here and get back the
results and so you know to make Chris a
little bit happier if he's in the room I
chose a team that won against Wisconsin
so you know that might be good for him
always looking out for you yes yeah I'm
not sure you know it may have you know
fallen off of a server I can change
things that doesn't change the
prediction at all so there's you know
this is nice it's consuming something
from other languages you can actually
use a lot of different input types here
from Python we support numpy arrays and
numpy data types but other languages if
you wanted to consume that from C sharp
or something that becomes impossible at
that point but if you want to just
purely publish Python functions that are
a little bit more interesting you can
otherwise if you want cross-language
Anor off you're stuck to these core data
types and that is basically all I had so
we have a site up we have a blog about
this stuff and the code is all up on
github and there's a nice description of
all the various decorators that are
there that you can use to tweak your
inputs and outputs and all of those
things and you can check out the
notebook service and start using this
stuff without really having to install
anything any questions yes
you can do pip install a charm oh I so
if you are in a notebook locally you can
do bang pip install as your ml and it'll
shell out and do the installation if
you're on our notebook services there or
if you're on someone else's notebook
service it might work there too yes so
so if you have a bunch of Python code
that's sitting somewhere that you want
to use there's actually a different way
that you can consume this decorator or
not consume the decorator at all even so
the decorator I put that in routes is so
if you have a bunch of code that you're
using that's in the notebook it's okay
so it's in a module somewhere and you
want to include that module along with
it so it's a little bit more difficult
than I'd like right now but there's in
here if I go through these inputs and
it's a little bit difficult to see
there's a files list and so you can
actually attach files with your upload
and those will go along so you can
attach that module and it'll be uploaded
and you can import it and use it now the
thing that makes that a little bit more
difficult is it's going to end up in
this directory called script bundle and
so you'll have to add that to sis top
path in order for you to be able to
import it yes so in the published
decorator if I this this doesn't show it
very well if I go to where I published
over here
so we will not automatically attach it
for you it's a interesting idea we do do
some module resolution so if you refer
to a module that is globally available
we will pickle that over in a way that
it will be reloaded and will reimport it
for you maybe we should consider doing
that in the in the case where we're
uploading from a notebook as well
there's two scenarios here really well
and one is uploading from a notebook
where we do all this magic serialization
but you can also just have some Python
files and upload those and in that case
we have the source code on disk and so
it's a much easier problem but you still
have to manually attach extra Python
files that you want to use in the
notebook case I think we could be a
little bit smarter but we aren't right
now yes and the files list if I can find
where I publish here you can do files
equals and you can provide a list of
things and that is basically like your
requirements but we can make that a
little more seamless I think yes
anyone else all right thank you